le ministre la parole est à madame marie
jo zimmermann
merci beaucoup monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le premier ministre
notre industrie automobile doit faire
face à la concurrence des autres pays de
l'union européenne
il faut donc la protéger en évitant de
modifier trop brutalement la fiscalité
comme on le constate avec le diesel
le groupe psa vient d'annoncer des
mesures de restructuration qui concerne
plus de 2000 emplois et cela s'explique
en partie par les mesures fiscales
prises à l'encontre de ce diesel le
diesel est pourtant l'un des points
forts des constructeurs français
automobiles la plus grande usine de
moteurs diesel au monde se trouve en
france à trémery or les investissements
dans l'automobile sont très importants
et ne s'amortit ce que sur une période
longue
c'est pourquoi la mission parlementaire
sur l'automobile demande que
l'alignement fiscale se fasse sur cinq
ans comme au minimum incompressible le
ministre du budget d'ailleurs avait
accepté ce principe les anciens diesel
je le concède était paul polluants mais
il est regrettable qu'on s'appuie sur
ceux ci et sur le problème de fortes
vagues and pour justifier l'explosion de
la fiscalité d'autant que les
constructeurs français ont
considérablement amélioré les nouveaux
moteurs et qu'aujourd'hui un moteur
diesel rejette deux fois moins de gaz à
effet de serre qu'un moteur à essence
dans ces conditions l'annnonce de la
ministre de l'environnement en faveur
d'un alignement fiscale sur deux ans est
une aberration économique notre
industrie a besoin de temps pour adapter
ses usines
faute de cela on risque de casser une
dynamique et de poser un problème pour
notre pour notre industrie automobile
face au concert européen
une fois de plus monsieur le ministre on
est en présence d'un cohérence
gouvernementale
monsieur le premier ministre je vous
demande de me répondre clairement
la convergence fiscale entre le diesel
et l'essence sera t-elle étalé sur cinq
ans ou sur deux ans faute de poids le
secteur automobile ne sera plus
compétitif
merci la parole comme ceux christophe
sirugue secrétaire d'état chargé de
l'industrie
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
marie jo zimmermann un mot tout d'abord
pour souligner le redressement de la
filière automobile qui a été un élément
extrêmement important
et pour ceux qui parfois s'interroge sur
le rôle de l'état dans le domaine
industriel
je crois important de rappeler que c'est
grâce à l'engagement qui a été fait
auprès de psa comme de renault que nous
avons ce redressement sur le point plus
spécifiques que vous évoquez madame la
députée je veux bien sûr rappelé combien
cette convergence sur la fiscalité entre
le diesel et l'essence est un élément
important
un amendement a été déposée par madame
delphine batho qui a été d'ailleurs
repris par la commission des finances et
qui prévoit un alignement à 5 ans ce que
le gouvernement soutient pour que les
choses soient claires par rapport à
votre question très précise à laquelle
je réponds très précisément je précise
par ailleurs qu'il y a bien évidemment
dans cette décision à venir à la fois un
enjeu environnemental mais aussi un
enjeu industriel puisque je rappelle que
cela permettra au constructeur
finalement d'adapter leur production à
l'égard de ses employés monsieur
motorisations diesel de la même manière
que cela permettra de ne pas subir une
dialyse à sion trop importantes qui
pourraient venir perturber la production
de nos constructeurs
j'ajoute que cela permettra aussi
d'éviter un recul pour les constructeurs
français au bénéfice de constructeurs
étrangers qui ont des modèles hybrides
et qui ont par ailleurs des productions
low cost de bénéficier de cette
opération pour toutes ces raisons
madame la députée la décision en tout
cas qui sera examiné ce rapport
favorable à l'amendement qui est proposé
de alignement sur cinq ans de cette
fiscalité je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre